women's nature is just very selfish I
Can't Tell You Why
um completely it's this way but I see no
evidence that it's any other way now
does that mean every woman acts on her
nature no but the problem is uh we can't
have honest conversations about these
topics because everybody thinks their
woman is special and I've interviewed
many men that thought their women was
were special when they got married and
then they found out that she was exactly
the same and the truth of the matter is
that Instagram changes women it gives us
leverage to the point or at least
perceived level to the point where we
think we are better than the men that
are on our level and I don't I don't
think this can really be disputed when
you see women calling themselves 10 and
let's look at the media when women have
been pandered to in the media it's often
at the expense of men